part one of masters of the universe
revelation ends on a huge cliffhanger
with the fate of he-man and skeletor
revealed and hidden in the first five
episodes are a stack of clues you might
have missed which also predict what
could happen next
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing all the crucial
details from the new netflix he-man
series plus theories for part two
many thanks to world of tanks for
sponsoring this video
obviously spoilers ahead so take care
the ending of part one sees adam tila
and her band of heroes return to eternia
with the sword of power reforged thanks
to roboto's heroic sacrifice
the sword had been split in two when
he-man used it to absorb the exploding
orb of power that skeletor cracked open
at the beginning of the series
the energy from the orb not only killed
adam but also
nearly all the magic that held eternia
together vanished when each half of the
sword of power disappeared to praternia
and subternia aka heaven and hell
so when adam holds a restored sword
aloft and says by the power of greyskull
he's able to call back the power and
reinstate magic in eternia
the hall of wisdom becomes castle
greyskull again and the orb of power is
restored and locked away however just as
adam is about to complete the phrase and
transform into he-man
skeletor makes a surprise return and
stabs adam through his mid-drift with
his havoc staff
skeletor like he-man vanished when the
orb of power exploded in the first
episode and he reveals that to avoid
being completely destroyed by the blast
he hid his essence in evil lin's one
staff
skeletor's trick was hinted at a number
of times in earlier episodes such as
when eva lin's orb lit up mysteriously
and when it began whispering at one
point
and tila funnily enough was unwittingly
closer to the truth than she realized
when she made a jive by eva lin
in the third episode take no life advice
from the likes of eva lynn andra she's
the only one here carrying around a
skeletor in her closet
so after skeletor's shocking defeat of
he-man which must be the first time in
the animated franchise's history
the villain takes a sword of power for
himself and says the magic words which
transform him into a god version of
himself
skelly god now i skeletor
and master of the universe
now let's talk about that possibly
lethal stabbing that skeletor landed on
adam
notice the location of the wound which
is roughly around the same place in the
middle of the body where adam stabbed
skeletor in the first episode and we
know that
he managed to survive that you finally
used that sword the way it was meant to
be used
by the way skeletor's line there is a
nod to how in the filmmation animated
series he-man never used his sword in a
violent way against his opponents
and as a kids show the series as a whole
also shied away from
serious violence masters of the universe
revelation is a continuation of the 80s
series however it's clearly a lot darker
with real fights taking place between
the characters with some of them even
trying to kill each other
and given this darker path for the new
series i think that initially
in part two adam could well be confirmed
dead
this would hit particularly hard as he
was told before that if he left paternia
this
next death would probably not allow him
back into heaven
if you were to return to eternia you
might never
be able to come back here you would end
as mortals do
in dirt however there is precedence for
he-man dying in the franchise
specifically the he-man thundercats
comic book crossover
where adam also died and came back to
life
after being brutally stabbed with the
sword of power in the books adam was
initially able to heal his mortal wounds
by holding on to the sword while saying
his classic catchphrase
later however adam died but was
resurrected after being entombed with a
sword of power
in the netflix show we might see
something similar in part two
with tila and the other heroes banding
together again this time to find a way
to take the sword of power from skeletor
and revive
adam even lin might also be a key part
of that which i'll talk more about
shortly orco is another major character
who appeared to die
but i suspect he might not have in the
land of the dead episode orco confronted
his fears that he'd never be able to
control his magical abilities
as he and the team tried to leave
subternia scareglow
arrived to attack them one final time in
a display of magical mastery orco froze
the falling rocks that were about to
fall on tila and the others then bravely
fended off scurglow giving them an
opportunity to escape
look i'm doing it i'm not afraid
he can't scare me orco then trapped
scareglow with his magic rings and tried
to blast him away
demon be gone go back to your
shadow the resulting explosion saw orko
and skurglow vanish
while throwing teela and co through the
portal to britannia with just a fragment
of orco's cloak
floating through the door as it closed
when adam discovered what happened he
built a memorial stone to honor his
fallen friend
assuming that he died however i don't
think that's the case
in fact orco's battle with skurglow in
the underworld may have actually turned
his character into a much darker version
for part two
and just before i reveal the truth about
dark orco i want to
thank this video sponsor world of tanks
world of tanks is an epic online team
game with over 100 million players
worldwide
and it's free to play in glorious hd on
your pc the games just launched a huge
gi joe crossover event with gi joe
breakthrough and
cobra battle operational assault tank
styles that runs till july 30th with our
special invite code you'll get free gi
joe and cobra emblems to customize your
tanks
and if you complete one of the event's
special themed missions you'll get extra
awards to fully kit out your tank with
bonus decals and inscriptions
world of tanks is full of authentic
historical detail and with over 550
tanks available you'll feel like a real
commander
plan a campaign with teammates and
defeat your enemies in over 40 battle
arenas
download the game for free right now and
during registration use the invite code
gi joe 21 to activate
in-game missions and receive free gi joe
emblems to decorate your tanks
the code also gets you a t14 tank tier 5
500 000 credits and seven days of a
premium account completely free
the download link can invite code in the
video description
to understand why we may be getting dark
orca in part two
we need to look at what happened to orko
in the dc universe versus the masters of
the universe comics
in that comic book storyline orco ended
up absorbing an evil force when he tried
to destroy the skull of power
and that unlocked the mental barriers
that have been holding him back
transforming him into dark orco that's
an interesting parallel with what
happens to orca in the land of the dead
where he explained how he struggled with
magic when he was young but then we see
him master it later in his showdown with
skurglow
during that crucial battle orco summoned
an immense amount of magic
and tried to banish the villain similar
to how he tried to destroy the skull of
power in the comics
that attempt to defeat skurglow who was
holding onto orko during the explosion
which followed may have transformed the
trollon into something
else for example if he absorbed some of
the evil being's megalomaniac traits and
wicked powers
the gold rings that orco conjured during
his encounter with scareglow are similar
to the fiery rings of magic that dark
orco uses in the comic and the shadow
beasts that attack orca and evil lin in
subternia
are a little reminiscent of the horde
that dark orco unleashes in the comic
we might find that in part two of
revelation dark orco has replaced
scurglo as the ruler of the underworld
commanding an army of shadow monsters
himself now
i think introducing dark orco could add
another intriguing element to the show
as it would be quite unexpected and in
keeping with the darker themes and tone
of the new series
my other big prediction for part two and
beyond is that although eva lynn
switched back to skeletor's side she may
end up betraying him and even helping
the good guys again in the future i
really was starting to like you kids
perhaps even lynn thought it was best to
feign she was still loyal to her
villainous boss in that moment with a
view to potentially usurping him at a
later point
after all she regretted some of the time
she'd spent working for him
instead of fulfilling my destiny i spent
a lifetime helping him fulfill his
in the 80s animated series evelyn
sometimes carried out her
own schemes independent of skeletor in
fact in the episode the witch and the
warrior when lynn found herself having
to work with teela she revealed that
what she was really after was her own
power i have no loyalty to skeletor it
is power i want
someday i'll seize it from him i very
much expect that at some
point in revelation evil lin will end up
being full-on resentful of being
skeletor's sidekick
on top of that i think she may have
grown genuinely fond of tila and the
gang and we saw a glimpse of that
when she opened up to orco during their
time together in the underworld
no they didn't call me evil i added that
part later
lynn also used the last of her magic to
conjure the doorway that would take them
all from subternia to pre-ternia which
orco said
proved that she might not be so bad deep
down turns out nobody's born
evil so if skeletor doesn't give lin any
real opportunities for power in part two
which i don't expect he will now he's
skelegod i think she may well end up
turning against him and
even possibly helping teela out as well
we also need to talk about tila as there
are many hints to a secret side of her
that hasn't yet
been fully revealed in fact there were
several moments in part one where
somebody was about to reveal a big
secret about her but they got cut off
there's something i have to tell you oh
no we don't have time for because you
have a special don't you understand tila
there's something
don't i don't want to hear it the secret
that everyone seems to want to tell
taylor is that
spoiler alert her mother is the
sorceress of castle grey skull
this was something revealed to teela in
the second episode of the filmation
series
you are my own daughter you will take my
place
as the mystic guardian of grayskull at
the time however the sorceress decided
to wipe tina's memory of that knowledge
you have other deeds to do you must
forget what you have learned today
and this secret is why the sorceress
calls teela to castle greyskull when she
fears she might die during skeletor's
attack
i wanted to see you tita one last time
me we see how taylor has been avoiding
dealing with a sense that she's
different
when the evil version of herself
confronts her in subtania
pretending to be ordinary when you know
deep down you are so much more
and how that must terrify you
taylor admits to scareglow that she's
never understood her power but then
proves her connection to her magical
heritage as she manifests the missing
piece of the sword of power by herself
what are you notice these three marks
that appear on tila's forehead
momentarily as she creates a sword as i
think we'll see those again
in the future as the original filmation
series suggests
teela may take over from her mother the
sorceress as a guardian of grey skull
should she ever die
or need to step down and although teela
was able to call on her power that one
time in the underworld
she will need to fully embrace her
magical side if she wants to take over
that role
so what did you think of motu revelation
and do you have any theories on what
could happen next and did you spot any
other details or interesting easter eggs
let me know in the comments below
if you enjoyed this then leave a thumbs
up and subscribe for more videos like
this
you can tap left to check out my next
video or tap right for something else
you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers